what do we mean when we say all and even
functions well what do we mean when we
say odd and even numbers we say odd it
even they're two categories that help us
to say some numbers they're special
right some numbers are odd
some are even summer you know neither
right you got weird numbers like saying
you know one and a half is that okay
so not all numbers fit into these
categories but the numbers that do
they're useful and they follow a lot of
rules which are helpful to us okay now
I'm going to leave it to you and I ask
you this next week to try and work out
hmm okay I know what these are and
you're gonna know what these mean after
I finish talking to you but why they
call butters like these really gonna
have much to do with these why they call
it odd and even functions why do we give
them those names okay so I said they're
categories these are categories is worth
know categories for describing functions
according to their symmetry symmetry is
the key
now back you can see a similarity like I
said sometimes on summer even some in
either in the same way some functions
odd some even and some are neither
because they don't have any kind of
symmetry right so uneven function is
actually a very special sort of subset
of all the functions out there okay and
you already know tons of odd and even
functions we just haven't given them the
names okay so let's start with even
functions what kind of function has even
symmetry well Y could be a square just
throw us up a really small one of this
history exception to the rule we don't
even put any details on here I just want
you to see it because immediately you
will see the symmetry this is an even
function
what kind of symmetry how would you
describe the symmetry that a has yeah
yeah so if I took on the y axis put a
straight line there right sorry very
straight okay you can sort of imagine it
like a mirror okay uh what do mirrors do
they reflect okay so another way to say
this is its reflection or that's the
Lotus Rabbit reflectional symmetry and
importantly it's it's always actually
got to be around the y axis
this parts really important if I were to
take this graph right and move it over a
little bit
say to draw y equals X minus 1 squared
okay same graph what difference
yeah good if the whole lot including its
axis of symmetry has moved over one unit
okay no he's a funny thing okay and
hopefully this will shed someone a wife
on even this function still has a kind
of symmetry but it doesn't have this
kind of symmetry because it's not around
the y axis is around some other place
okay so all of the punches we can look
at around there can anyone think of any
other even functions the top there yeah
so when you draw this out okay what do
you got you've got this part this is the
part that you're used to right because
that's the 0 to 360
so YouTube higher to draw a lot but of
course you can go the other direction
and again it's it's got that reflection
you can see okay before we leave off
this those are those are the most common
examples you can really take there any
polynomial with and even catalog so I
could say you solve for X to the 4 also
even symmetry
it's the 6x to the 800 they'll all be
even okay you have a think about why now
there's my arm is my visual definition I
think you guys could now pick out an
even function or not I want to give you
an algebraic definition as well so
visual algebraic
now when I give you the algebraic
definition you might think what are we
using this because it's so much more
intuitive and common-sense I even a very
young child could understand this
whatever that's a give you be weird okay
the reason I'm going to give you this is
because this kind of is not very good
when you want to prove something I have
some once it's you okay prove this is
even and you're like well it kind of
looks like the thing like different this
side of even silent it's the same right
well let's have an airy-fairy and not
really proof quality okay but this is so
what does it mean algebraically for a
function to be even it means function is
even then that function when you put an
X in will be exactly the same if you put
negative x in that make sense so this
example is you put one in you get one
you put negative one in and still get
one these things will always be the same
okay that's the algebraic definition
when you look on the sheet you've got at
the moment it says prove this okay
you're gonna have to do it using this
fact okay this is where you want to
arrive so as an example to prove a
function even let's consider y equals x
squared or ever meant to prove there's
my f of X I know what this side looks
like I know what my left-hand side looks
like I need my right hand side okay this
one required to true so I'll say f of
minus a is equal to okay if you wanted
to be Qi you can say well that's x
squared right but of course a proof
means show me the logic and in steps
don't take shortcuts right so in fact
this is one look at the function
notation right if I'm saying f of that
it means everywhere I see an X I'm
slightly - and it may seem a little
excessive to put in this but again I'm
trying to make the logic obvious
okay and that's equal to X with that's
equal to f of X so you can see yeah I'm
done right but see you can say therefore
and that's what you be doing all that
[ __ ] now even symmetry what is odd
symmetry hmm yeah you might think we'll
have another option right would be a
rather different axis okay
para problem with that though is that if
it were around say the x axis and we've
got a bunch of functions like that like
Taylor the circle or that sideways
probably exactly but the problem when
the ears are well it's a lot of function
right and it should be to these
symmetric around that way it would have
to be a relation cuz you've got to get
multiple outputs for the one import so
instead of one symmetry on symmetry my
example this is not white we have
squared it's y equals execute okay now
we talked before we said this has a
symmetry was obviously not the same
there's there's no and you can't pick an
axis about which you can say oh yeah
it's uh it's that axis or that axis even
if you like sneaky and go in an angle
okay
it still doesn't reflect across like Phi
to a gun if I said why cuz minus X put a
line through okay and you twisted your
hand and you reflected one part of it
you wouldn't get the other side you see
that in fact
if I were to reflect this pot I would
get this okay it's not a function of
what so what we agree it has a kind of
saturated what kind is it happy yeah
that's right so you've seen this before
like an u7 we looked at different kinds
of shapes right there's two names for
this we can say it's symmetrical about
point so handsome point symmetry I think
an even more intuitive way to say it is
if I instead of flipping it reflecting
it right that's like a physical action I
could take this shape and I could twist
it I could rotate it around could not I
could take this half and spin it around
and you get the other half right so you
can also call it rotational symmetry
okay I think that kind of I think that's
more intuitive to maybe someone quit
symmetry what about the point okay
where's rotations at oh I got it I know
turn okay
now I gave you an apology Bragg
definition for even this before okay so
what do you would be an algebraic
definition for odd this let's see
hmm now I left this all on here because
it is super super close the definition
for oddness and the definition for
evenness you still got the function and
has a relationship to the function when
you put the opposite value in but
doesn't have the same relationship
they're not identical what's the
difference its flipped that's it so some
people find this a little confusing
because they are so similar alright so
maybe you want to put this in like a
different color or something like that
if one wanted to prove the function were
odd for example y equals x what's the
different table that's boring um X cubed
there's one example can someone give me
another it's about five okay ah this is
interesting or even powers are even
function even functions and all odd
powers odd functions now that's
interesting
it's not the reason they could ordinary
functions but we'll get to that everyone
can anyone else think of it and there
are any kinds of other functions we know
about they're full of this kind of thing
okay we had kha'zix before so intrigue
terms you could use sine or you could
use tan both of them have this same kind
of symmetry okay can you see it do you
get it so let's go with sine X Y X how
would I prove that it's on so I should
probably okay I would say well if that's
what that is what's F of minus X well
it's I'm just going to replace every X
with a minus X okay and unfortunately
here you know you can't really it sort
of does look like back to back black
magic if you're looking from the outside
you guys know as an identity that that
is equal to this right that's one of the
ones you learn very early on okay so
that is negative f of X it's not really
many steps of logic you could
so enough proof okay I'm done this is
the format it's gonna always got F tell
me what F of minus X is and do whatever
our direct stuff you need to to show
this okay